so the Rockets win the tip hey everyone
its Peter Brown standing in for a
freelancer Josiah or now den to review
NBA 2k16 an NBA team it's Howard with
the draw NBA 2k16 is a tale of substance
and style loaded with interesting things
to do and an unprecedented degree of
personality for the series Sudan step in
my world is the best-looking and most
robust NBA 2k game to date but on the
court it can be a struggle to find your
rhythm the controls have expanded to
give you the ability to direct and feed
a man the ball in the post picture pass
behind you and manage the position and
timing of screens these inclusions find
mixed success but the new setup paired
with smarter offensive and defensive a I
shine spotlights on the game's woefully
inadequate tutorials it's a shame to
sense once you begin to correctly time
screens and master the juice and fakes
tied to the pro stick NBA 2k16 plays
like a dream movement feels natural and
encourages creative play partially
because the AI is better at applying
pressure especially against higher rated
players the dedicated bounce pass and
lob buttons give you even greater
control of the floor allowing you to
more smoothly fake toward the basket and
slip a slick pass to a shooter in the
corner it's just frustrating that you're
given so little help along the way
a little bit of a magic egg here pulling
off a Houdini to make that tension /
director Spike Lee's live into dreams
stories NBA 2k16 s most prominent
edition and it's the first portion of
your journey through my career money you
still customize your own player all the
way from his weight and height to the
crook of his nose but any player you
craft steps into the shoes of NBA
hopeful and Harlem native freak short
for frequency vibrations from high
school to college and eventually the big
leagues you follow freakin his circle of
family and friends as they deal with all
the difficult questions that come along
with the life of a professional athlete
the story opens strong by giving you
freedom to choose your high school in
college but the decision making is
quickly snatched from your grip once
your career begins to take off
unfortunately this player freedom is a
facade as the story plays out in a
frustratingly linear fashion where the
only thing you really control is what
team you sign with and how you allocate
your stats a dialogue can get corny
especially when you're angry team owner
awkwardly throws out Street lingo easy
and I did not grow up in the hood but we
like but the writing and delivery is
leaps and bound ahead of what's been
used in years past this is the best my
career has been and the transition from
high school hoops to the professional
league is well paced and much more
personal the second act of my career
asks you to manage a full year's
schedule regular games are supplemented
with off days when you're free to speak
with interested brands coordinated by
your agent practice drills with your
team or spend time with other NBA stars
to help improve your image well could it
improve the career mode is even a basic
tutorial it's a trial by fire for anyone
unfamiliar with a standard flow of the
game and even veteran players will find
that the tweet control scheme demands
plenty of practice to make perfect as
always there's always so much more to do
beyond the my career mode and each of
the diverse team types our main
entertainer
the ever so addictive my team pushes you
to invest time and resources into your
slapdash team to earn new booster packs
and cards to bolster your roster the
temptation to drop real-life cash on
better packs and players can be strong
but the collectible card carnival adds
enough new challenges to remain
satisfying without pressuring you to pay
a premium the franchise my league and my
GM modes also make a strong return
giving you freedom to relocate your team
reconfigure their look and even test out
your rookie prospects in the summer
league if you prefer to create an NBA
sandbox where you control a franchise
for full 80 seasons and can even invite
up to 29 other real people to join your
personal NBA fantasy
my league in its new online component is
your destination but working against the
game success is a steady current of
connectivity issues even after years of
online woes the nagging framerate
stability and connection lapses persist
they're not quite as damning I found
plenty of online matches that hitched
and sputtered far less than what's been
seen in the past but connectivity issues
reset my created characters appearance
on multiple occasions and even kicked me
out of games NBA 2k16 often pits you
against its own technical limitations
rather than the person controlling the
other team NBA 2k16 brings you in with
its welcoming personality and expanded
game modes but it can sometimes gently
push you away with unexplained
intricacies still the fact that NBA 2k16
is a great basketball experience can't
be ignored few sports games come close
to providing a more authentic fun
virtual representation of the real thing
and even if this is the least
user-friendly entry in years I can't
stop playing it
are those pecking order games where you
try to get some separation so let's take
a look at the starters for the Dallas
map
about that what range on that shot tuck
let's amazing